what's up everybody we just received
some awesome exciting unexpected news
and that is we have more promo art for
Avengers for not too long ago maybe we
can have two weeks ago we had our first
look at promo art further than just four
if you haven't seen it check out the
link above and it's a picture that I'm
shown right here if you want the
breakdown check out the video but these
new pictures are only the second look
that we've gotten at anything related to
Avengers 4 so as you can see here we
have the Hulk Hawkeye war machine rocket
nebula Captain Marvel and Thanos the
characters are in the same poses that
they were in for the first leaked photo
this just gives us a better look at the
characters so let's start off with the
Hulk as you can see here it looks like
he finally has an official uniform many
people believe that because the Hulk is
wearing this suit and if you look at his
face he looks a little bit more like
banner than he does the normal Hulk many
people believe that we're going to get
some sort of version of the merged Hulk
or professor Hulk then we have Hawkeye
and if you take a close look at his
boots he's actually wearing Ronan boots
I think it's all but known right now
that Clint Barton will give up the role
of Hawkeye in Avengers 4 and will take
on the mantle of Ronan and this promo
art leads us to continue to believe that
because of the boots then we have war
machine rocket and nebula and if you
take a look at war machine he looks a
lot more intense than he normally does
so in this photo right here compared to
the photos of the promo art and the
posters that we got for Avengers
infinity war he looks bigger
specifically the suit around his arms
and his legs it looks like they're given
him more firepower for Avengers 4 which
makes sense seeing as how the Avengers
are going up against somebody who wiped
out half the universe with the snap of
his fingers
then there's rocket racoon who actually
looks pretty normal or you know at least
as normal as you can for a talking
raccoon that is wearing clothes and then
you have nebula as well who doesn't look
too different from how she's looked in
guardians
the galaxy and Avengers infinity war but
the fact that we have primo art for them
means that they're probably going to
play a really big role in Avengers fort
nebula specifically because after all
she is the adopted daughter of Thanos
and not to mention in the comics she is
the one that wields the Infinity
Gauntlet taking it from Thanos and
Rocket Raccoon is the only one who's
left of the guardians of the galaxy so
both of these characters are going to be
pretty important in Avengers 4 next I'm
going to talk about Thanos because this
is the exact same photo that we saw
before
danos is wielding his sword which we
never saw in Avengers Infinity Ward
there was a toy that came out where he
was wielding his sword but again it was
never in the movie so maybe we'll see it
in Avengers 4 but who knows but also
take a look he's still wearing the
Infinity Gauntlet and it's perfectly
intact at the end of infinity war after
the snap the gauntlet was messed up
pretty badly but it seems like it's fine
I'm sure he just uses the time stone to
reverse it and make it all better again
and last but absolutely not least is
Captain Marvel this is a treat because
we have more than one pose for her right
here the one on the left is the one that
she's in the other leaked art in but the
two on the right are new this makes
sense because I think these are for toys
actually and Captain Marvel comes out
before Avengers infinity war so it would
make sense that they would make the toy
for Captain Marvel before they made all
the other ones what I love about these
photos is that they're showing the
energy around Captain Marvel's hands
Captain Marvel has the ability to shoot
light energy out of her hands but she
can also absorb energy which brings her
blast that she can shoot out up to par
with a nuclear explosion yeah pretty
powerful so I love that they're being
emphasized here so that's it for these
leaked photos I hope you all enjoyed
them it's always a treat because we
really haven't received anything for
Avengers for you yet just a couple of
photos so I hope this means that we're
gonna start to get more and more
concerning Avengers for let me know your
thoughts on these photos in the comments
below and don't forget to hit that like
button before you leave and subscribe to
my channel to stay up to date on
Avengers 4 thank you all so much for
watching stay classy Wolfgang
[Music]